well what we've heard is they were  moving from chromatosk over here in the  donbass region across to solidar  um and it turns out the moment solidar  we heard from the ministry of Defense uh  just overnight that has fallen to the  Russians or at least the majority has  fallen so it seems they found themselves  in the most dangerous part of the most  dangerous part of the war in Ukraine  um these were fighting age males uh it  looks as if they might have been in  military fatigues as well and uh whilst  it's entirely wrong to speculate what's  actually happened to them  um you know it doesn't look good and  they're clearly they were doing an  amazingly courageous job but they seem  to have found themselves in the wrong  place at the wrong time